Happy New Year are you ready are you
ready for a 2016 you dadgum right you
are and if you're not you better get
your button gear it's here baby it's
time to get with it it's time to buckle
that helmet on and go do something this
is your year and if it's not it's not
going to be anybody's fault but yours
you get to decide and I'm so excited
about this year I am so pumped I got up
so early this morning
ready to come back down here and get
this year started we have so many things
that Ramsey solutions happening this
year next week we launch Chris Hogan's
retire inspired book next Monday is
launch day I'm so pumped about this
we've been working on this forever and
I'm so excited to get to be a part of
this project and for Ramsey solutions to
be not only the publisher but the
promoter the whole thing the owner of
that whole project it's absolutely
incredible so we're excited about that
a lot of other things coming this year
they're going to be very exciting that
you're going to see that we've been
working on behind the scenes for a while
your life's the same way if you haven't
been working on some things behind the
scenes you need to get to work you get
to choose you get to choose what you're
going to do you know when I was a little
kid probably 10 12 years old my dad
started going to sales conferences he
was in the real estate business and he
started going to sales conferences and
one of the things they would always
bring up there one of the big dogs in
those days and speaking was Zig Ziglar
Zig and I became good friends later on
before he passed away Tom his son and I
are friends to this day we email back
and forth virtually every week and love
that family love those people because I
love Digg and that's what started the
thing but but when daddy went to those
conferences one things he came home with
was he came home telling us we needed to
set goals as kids he said you need to
set goals I wasn't real excited as a
twelve-year-old about setting goals
because I usually in that meant I was
going to do something he wanted me to do
but that's exactly what it was right but
we started
talking about way back there the idea of
setting goals and I kind of drifted away
from it in terms of consciously doing it
setting a goal I'm not talking about a
new year's resolution new year's
resolution something you did with too
much champagne I'm not talking about
that
I'm talking about really deciding I'm
going to move the needle in an area of
my life that's been frustrating me and
some of these areas I've been winning in
I'm going to win even bigger you've been
making money you want to make some more
money that's a good thing you've not
been taking care of your body but you're
going to get in shape that's a good
thing
so one of those is an area that's a
sweet spot one of those is an area maybe
you're struggling and it could be
reversed I don't know but but you know
you have to be conscious about that you
have to do it intentionally so I kind of
drifted away from it and then of course
when I started in business I started I
drifted gravitate back to the idea
because I kind of thought it's kind of
cheesy you know set gals in and it's
like positive thinking you can become
anything and it's all cheesy I thought
you know what it's that the problem is
it's true you will hit what you aim at
too many people sit around in a
smartphone world and say ready aim aim
aim aim aim aim aim aim aim aim aim aim
aim aim aim aim they never fire time to
fire ready aim fire it's not ready fire
aim either that's not cute it's not
funny
that just brings chaos that says you're
rash and you're not wise ready aim fire
that's how you hit something otherwise
you're that stupid kid in the backyard
shooting a bow and arrow straight up in
the air and hoping it doesn't come down
the top of your head dadgum ed and
you're running your life that way you
run your life that way and if you're all
laughing because we all did that when we
got a bow and arrow right I was that
stupid kid okay that and I played with
charts - so the other who came up with
that to give children charts large darts
as if we weren't going to play chicken
with them okay hello sidebar so you need
to set goals because otherwise you're
playing with charts and you're shooting
a bow and arrow up in the air and hoping
it didn't come down the top of your own
stupid head you have to aim
something and then you have to pull the
trigger intentionally otherwise you live
your whole life watching other people
succeed and now you and you digress so
far that you think reality TV is
entertaining that's when you know you've
hit bottom that when you're posting your
food on Instagram we know your life is
bad at that point you know that you
don't have enough going on in your life
that's quality that's inspiring that's
moving that's causing your blood to flow
it's causing your heart to beat it's
causing your adrenaline to be released
you got to do that stuff on purpose it
doesn't happen on accident so get your
pencil out are you ready there's areas
you need to set goals in and you need to
do them starting right now you need
physical goals are you going to lose
weight are you're going to get better
shape you can have a different resting
heart rate I don't know what it is you
can lift more weight you're going to run
a further distance you can run a half
marathon a marathon this year you're
gonna run a 5k for the first time in
your life you're gonna run for the first
time in your life when something wasn't
chasing you what is it you're going to
do with the physical goal about
intellectual goals how do I treat me
this week is a great tweet then during
the holidays he said my goal I wrote
down last year was to read a nonfiction
book every month because Dave you said
millionaires read a nonfiction book
every month on average he said I set
that goal I read 54 I didn't read 12
boom intellectual goals my wife set the
app up she's going to read through the
Bible this year again intellectual goal
spiritual goal combined career goals
what are your career goals are you gonna
do with your career is this the year
you're going to start your business or
about social goals but those people you
lie to and you say hey let's get
together for lunch and then you never do
write it down
have an intentional social goal my wife
says if I wasn't married to her we'd
have no friends oh yeah I'd have no
friends because she's real social and
I'm not I like people but I'm not social
there's a difference so I have to
intentionally do that financial goals
get out of debt you're listening the
Dave Ramsey show family goals you do
your family we've got
young kids that are married and some of
them are talking about babies and got
babies and what are your family goals
what are your goals you're going to have
it start having a date night with your
spouse or with your five-year-old
daughter men you know date your daughter
so she knows how to date a real man when
she's grown and knows how she should be
treated that the doors should be opened
the chair should be pulled out and the
check should be picked up where's she
going to get that if you don't date her
spiritual goals read through the Bible
I'm going to start attending church or
synagogue first time in my life I'm
going to go through this or that Bible
study day that's all great how do I do
that well when we come back from this
break I'm gonna walk you through the
five things you have to do for your
goals to be successful and you need to
do this stuff folks it'll rock your
world it'll change your life
you would not believe how many of the
things I'm doing right now that were
written down goals that we talked about
we laid out 10 15 even 20 years ago and
I'm living in them right now changes
everything ready aim fire you know why
most people don't win they don't bother
you have to bother it to be intentional
never again as American Express going to
call my house and ask my wife why she
would stay with a man that won't pay his
bills